And as far as tablets
are concerned,
yes, you could make some
OK images of your work
very quickly like we did
here, use the music box,
which you've seen before.
This one was made
with the tablet.
But always keep in mind
that the file size is not
even close to what we get
with a full size camera.
And it's certainly not as
convenient as a camera phone,
in my opinion.
But I thought I'd show you
something I was playing around
with a while ago.
And here's an image I made
of an area of a device.
And we could actually
see 30-micron structures.
I made the images with a tablet.
It's considerably cropped
from the full image.
Now here's the setup.
I put the tablet's camera
on "selfie" mode, that is,
using the front camera.
The idea is that you can see
exactly what the camera is
seeing and so that you
could make adjustments
to the set up in real time.
Here's the jeweler's lens
that I placed over the camera
in the tablet.
And here's the set up
from another angle.
Let's zoom in so that
you see how it looks.
So basically, I am making
a microscopic image
with this setup.
You can adjust the distance
of the lens from the device
by using different wooden
blocks, for example.
There are number of
companies selling supposedly
microscopic lenses, which you
attach to your phone or tablet,
but I'm not convinced
the quality of the optics
is what we want.
Here we see some very
fine detail, because
of the quality of the lens.
But unfortunately, the file
size as we said is pretty low,
but that is improving rapidly.
So this could be a
quick way of sharing
your work with your colleagues
through emails for example.
It's just something
to think about.